all right good morning everybody it's a
pleasure to welcome to introduce
vasilis
from microsoft research talking about
econometrics and uh
game theory and interactions with
machine learning as well uh
i'll be monitoring the online
questions and uh
i will interject myself during that
thank you everyone for coming yeah uh
one also announcement
in the afternoon we're also going to
have the town hall at the end of the
last session so please come if you want
to
you know bring ideas on what reading
groups you want to do during the
semester and other activities that you
might like to to have during the
semester that's the the place to discuss
that because we're gonna finalize the
the schedule by the end of the week
um
all right so yeah let me jump in so i'm
gonna be talking this hour and the next
hour on do you have the slides on oh i
didn't i didn't create the tiny url i'll
do it right after the uh the first
session sorry for that
um
i'll be talking for these two hours on
econometrics in games and auctions uh
it's going to be a relatively high level
given the richness of the literature
so i'll be presenting sort of the lay of
the land and some uh particular proofs
that i'll that i sort of like find
interesting uh and hopefully i'll give
you pointers to uh papers if you want to
read more uh for each of those sub areas
of econometrics and games
so what is the overall motivation our
goal is to be able to analyze data that
are coming from strategic interactions
these types of data could be looking
like
entry market entry data by competing
firms one concrete example that has been
analyzed in the literature is airline
market henry trying to understand why
some airlines enter some markets whereby
market here is a city pair
so why do some airlines choose to do
their art and others don't
markets could be a supermarket entering
a neighborhood so that's a market
or other retail markets
so we're trying to understand here why
did these participants in those markets
chose what they chose
and
what are the parameters of their
utilities how would they behave if the
market changes if there is a stock in
the market things like that
another prominent example is uh bidding
data from auctions
and this could be there are more
classical applications of auction theory
in procurement auctions for
drilling rights or for
other uh
you know
competitions that the government uh
holds or even more modern applications
such as online adoptions where multiple
bidders bid for odd slots on the
internet
as over there we want to understand
why did bidders bid what they bid
what is their value for the auction
that's being run
um what would change in their bidding
behavior if we change the mechanism
and this is these are the types of
questions
another
type of data
[Music]
another set of uh you know applications
that i'm not gonna go into but is also
very interesting for people especially
in the uh theoretical computer science
community to look into is uh
understanding data from strategic
network interactions so you would look
at the network that was forming based on
some strategic
considerations uh you know and trying to
understand what were the utilities of
people why they formed these links and
not others and then maybe you could make
policy decisions based on on the results
of that analysis
so these are some examples uh more
generally uh you know the the most
general framework that you can imagine
uh is the following very uh uh abstract
we're gonna be assuming that we have uh
uh samples uh zedi of observable
quantities from a game that's being
played repeatedly you know maybe you
resemble from the game that was being
played here being played there being
played there we're gonna imagine a
situation where the same type of game
with different parameters is being
played multiple times and we see all of
these samples
and
we assume that all of these games have
some underlying structural parameters
that are common and these are theta not
so this could be the parameter of a game
which could be my value for bidding in
this type of option or
my utility for forming a link to costas
or
my uh
the
impact of competing with another firm in
this particular market
type of market um
and what econometric theory from game
for games is trying to do as a field is
address identification and estimation
questions in a variety of game theoretic
models
assuming that players are playing
according to some kind of equilibrium
notion
more traditionally nas equilibrium but
we'll see maybe in the second hour
some recent work within the theoretical
computer science community trying to
move away from nash equilibrium
or more traditionally would be nas
equilibrium or variance of it
generalizations of it for say dynamic
games or you know
repeated games
if you want to have a very stylized
example in mind of particular
cases that have been analyzed and that
we're going to also go into more detail
in the in the rest of the talk
here's a very concrete example uh you
want to analyze entry games with private
socks
so in this example we have two firms
deciding to whether to enter a market
and this you could
imagine for example the airline story
where you have two airlines trying to
choose whether they're gonna
participate in this particular city pair
route
so what we observe in the data is entry
decisions so whether this firm entered
or not in the market
from different
markets in the world
um
and for simplicity here we're going to
assume that all of those markets have
two participants
um
those two participants have some profits
from entering
uh so this is the profit of participant
one
which is
um
some
part of that profit is determined by the
state of the market
so x
say are some observable characteristics
of the market
or the particular market for from its
sample
and so the state of the market which is
x the characteristics of the market
uh affect the payoff that the profit is
expecting to get
out of that out of entering
but importantly what makes it into a
game is that
uh
the my payoff is going to get a
a hit uh
by
depending on whether the other player is
going to enter so if the other player
enters
my utility is going to be uh changed by
a delta one which typically would be
negative so my utility will be decreased
if the other player enters
and not if the other player doesn't
enter
then there's also some private sock in
each of those samples that we have which
is very
idiosyncratic to that particular sample
and which serve like is any uh
heterogeneity across these markets that
cannot be captured by the observable
characteristics that we have and which
are typically not
entering the uh yeah so that's that's
true so this is sort of like a the
analog of a noise in a regression
problem
and similarly for
participant number two we're going to
have this profit equation
with the assumption that if i describe
it
yeah so yeah
so
in this example
because this is the type of games that
i'm going to analyze in this store
because i didn't have enough time i'm
not going to go into the other
type of assumption so we're going to be
looking at games where these are using
graphic shocks
are
private to a player so they're not
observed by both players
and
you know across markets we're going to
assume that they're iav the most
important part is that when a player
decides whether or not
they don't observe what was the sort of
the other firm
this changes completely
the
type of game so if a player does not
deter the other players
error then this becomes a game of
incomplete information
we're going to be
typically assuming in our solution
concept that they have some belief about
that sock
and we're going to be looking at a
bayesian game where they best respond in
expectation over that belief
importantly um
and well if if they knew the other uh
players sucks and we're in a complete
information game
and basically their the equilibrium is
going to be some nas equilibrium of the
complete information
why this changes completely the
econometric analysis is that in the case
of complete information
each player when they best respond
they know something that we as
econometricians when we look at the data
we don't observe
and so this completely changes the types
of estimators that we can build and the
types of identification strategies in
particularly when we're when you're in
such situations of complete information
where we don't know
some parameter that the player uses to
best respond typically the uh the
parameters that we care about are not
point identified we can only get bounce
on those parameters
there are typically multiplicity of
equilibria coming from the fact that
this is a very sort of like a
non-random game so there's no smoothness
in the randomness of the epsilon and so
typically they're multiplicity of
equilibria and this multiplicity also uh
leads to partial identification of the
parameters greenpeace
but in that the incomplete information
case which is harder for the player is
actually easier for the econometrician
that we're going to look uh into today
because
the player when they best respond
observes exactly sort of what we observe
we're gonna we're gonna be fine and
we're gonna be looking at the techniques
for point identification of those
parameters which could be delta one and
beta one delta two and beta two so these
are the parameters that we care about
understanding how competition affects
player entry
and how the market state affects player
entry so these are the quantities that
we're trying to understand from the data
that we observe
so why is econometric analysis in games
useful
um first of all you know from a
scientific perspective these quantities
could be economically meaningful you
know like the how does competition
affect
you know like uh
other players firms you could or how
different states of the market affect
the payoffs you could just give economic
meaning to them and this could be just
uh
science there could be just scientific
interests
another more sorry
economic analysis for so many years and
psychometric theory is based on that but
we'll see that the reason you know the
recent results that we
have been working on in the this year's
community also look at learning in games
and things like that uh you know the
violence of that so here i would say
that there could be situations where nas
equilibrium may be in games where
players are
are sort of like uh intelligent firms
that have you know departments that are
gonna strategize over whether they're
gonna enter or not maybe there there is
enough market analysis and enough
analysis and enough economies in that
department that the nasa equilibrium is
going to be chosen so it could be
relevant in some situations
uh maybe not in more complex markets
like odd auctions where these are
algorithmic bidders and you know
they don't really know exactly what that
market is the paves from every game is
are so small that it's not a big
decision so let's just try and see what
happens it's going to be more the
behavior but maybe more uh important
decisions they're going to be more
analysis and maybe the players play at
the equilibrium and maybe the game is
not so complex that harness results
from the tcs community kicking for that
particular situation and they managed to
find an equipment or they would be
smooth enough that you make assumptions
about the beliefs that it becomes some
sort of like easy problem in a
continuous space
um
the
the other important reason for
understanding those parameters is to be
able to perform counter factual analysis
so what would happen if we change the
game
this is especially interesting here
because uh we're we're imagining
situations where we completely change
the mechanisms underlying the data that
we observe and then we're trying to
predict
this is completely different from the
standard paradigms sort of saying
machine learning
where we assume that we're
you know like the data that we're going
to try to predict are coming from the
same distribution as the data where we
that we used to analyze
um because we completely changed all of
the mechanisms underlying the behavior
of players if we change the game
so this is there's a huge extrapolation
here and
in some regimes maybe you could apply
techniques from machine learning to do
the extrapolation
but here we're talking about a
completely different distribution and
without any mechanistic assumption on
how these two distributions are coupled
based on you know ideas from game theory
and uh
and you know like behavioral assumptions
of on players it would be very hard to
do this extrapolation without structural
assumptions
so in some sense structural econometrics
help you extrapolate even more of course
at the caveat that
the extrapolation is correct if your
structural model was correct
so you can go further but your your
results are a bit more brittle to your
assumptions
uh similarly
maybe we care in markets about
performance measures that depend on
those unknown parameters
maybe we care about what was the welfare
in that game that was actually being
played maybe that welfare depends on the
private values of players
so if we want to be able to calculate
that performance measure we need to
infer
uh those parameters first
and then we can also use these
approaches to test game theoretic models
maybe we
estimate structural parameters here this
is going to
predict some type of behavior when we
make some change in the mechanism if we
don't observe that behavior
we can invalidate
some types of you know behavioral
assumptions in games
i should say that econometric theory in
games is a very rich literature
especially in the last
25 or so years um
uh i'm going to be posting this this
picture
with along with the slides so it's very
hard to read but this is sort of like my
attempt to try to create a map of the
literature in economic games for someone
that that wants to jump in and read from
the beginning and knows nothing about
that
uh
some uh distinctions on the different uh
uh
the streams of the literature is we know
whether we're looking at
games with discrete actions so binary
decision games
or continuous actions like auctions
where your choice is a bid
so auctions is a whole sub-field of
econometrics and games and there's been
works on understanding estimation of
parameters under the independent private
values model or under correlated
values or affiliated common values
within the discrete you know there's a
distinction of whether you're looking at
static strategic interactions so one
sort or dynamic repeated strategic
interactions with a state where the
actions change the state
and in the static again as i said before
it makes a big difference whether you're
in the complete information setting
where
techniques like multiplicity of
equilibria and set inference kicking or
whether you're in the bayesian setting
where point identification is more
relevant
and
techniques like two-stage estimators
that we're going to talk about in this
hour
are
the standard approach for estimating
parameters in these games
all of this is based on more more
classical econometric theory and these
are sort of like if you want to read
about more classical economic theory i'm
going to do a very brief primer
on uh the you know like the theoretical
foundations and the statistical
foundations of econometric theory
typically it's large sample asymptotic
theory
non-parametric and semi-parametric
estimation
and
[Music]
some more eclectic topics that are
particular to learning in games is this
set estimation
uh
literature in statistics
all right so
let me now just first jump into the
brief primer of on econometric tier
which will
not be particular to
econometrics and games but just in
general when we we're you're trying to
estimate some parameter of a model based
on data and what are the techniques and
tools that are typically being used
any questions about the introduction
so
the standard setup in econometric theory
we're given a sequence of iid data
points
uh
and each of those data points is drawn
from some distribution that's
parameterized
by some unknown parameter fit or not
and given those symbols we're trying to
recover that
unknown structural parameter
of course there's generalizations
correlated the uh serially correlated
with weekly whatever but like this is
the the more standard setup
the parameter space where this unknown
parameter lies in is
gonna characterize the type of
statistical problem that we're dealing
with and the hardness of it
so if that parameter is say a vector in
some finite dimensional space
then we're essentially in a parametric
model and we're doing parametric
estimation
if that unknown parameter many times
could actually be a whole function maybe
we don't know the demand curve
in a in a market
and so the unknown parameter is this
whole function and we want to do
non-parametric estimation of that
function without making parametric
assumptions
many times
in econometrics we're in a mixture of
these two situations
where
we care about some parameter
that we impose we impose some parametric
assumptions for some parts of the of the
world
and we care about that parameter
but we allow some uh other uh parts of
our data generating process
to be uh unmodeled to be left
non-parametric
uh and we don't really care about those
uh and so
it's this weird situation where in order
to estimate the parameter that you're
interested in
you need to estimate all of those
complicated non-parametric functions
which you do not care about
but
they are required
in order to be able to estimate the
target parameter of interest
uh and and this is sort of like the uh
semi-parametric inference literature
uh and typically questions there will be
can we be robust to the estimations of
those complicated objects
okay where's the question oh yeah so my
question is
your first bullet says given the
sequence of id data points
should i ask you that you have
distribution over everything or like
sort of like in the entry game you
talked about before
you know kind of like the exit starters
and the markets could be just arbitrary
with some nice other things distribution
where everything you put distribution
over the markets everything yeah
oh yeah
um
so
you know the first main goal uh if we
knew this population distribution d of
theta naught
uh
if we actually knew the distribution
does that pinpoint fit or not exactly
right so let's be identification
question
if i give you the sort of like the
distribution if you give you infinite
samples
can you tell me what theta naught is or
are there multiple
theta notes that are observationally
equivalent right
and the second is the estimation we want
to devise an algorithm that outputs a
parameter theta hat when given n sample
that converges to theta naught at some
rate
yeah this is even
beyond metrics in games this is just
estimation theory in some sense it's not
like uh
i'm just responding to multiplayer
[Music]
you know you can even even for the
dynamic game setup you can still
formulate inference questions that look
like this
after you you know like uh you
if for example you look at samples from
different markets as independent samples
when you look at trajectories you could
also you know like
look you know look at independent
samples of trajectories for instance
uh but this is
yeah this has nothing to do with uh
nothing has nothing to do this is not
specialized in econometrics in games
this is just
like inference
and you can think of it in the context
of the
static and the game that i mentioned how
would you go about
applying
this framework
yeah as i said in the second slide
because it would be something meaningful
like if you know what is the effect of
uh of education on income but just you
could just say that right so this could
be a parameter based on your data points
right uh
so you could be you could use it to
understand if you change the game
somehow maybe you're now in a new market
with the different x
what how what what equilibrium behavior
they expect to see
if i change x over here what do i expect
my the
how do i expect my firms to behave
um
or
uh you know like uh maybe i care about
some uh welfare measure that depends on
those parameters and i want to calculate
that because i care that whether they
whether the equilibrium is approximately
efficient
so i need to estimate that
uh
question one uh at least the player i
mean we that we are trying to the to
solve the task do we know the family d
and we just trying to learn the
parameter yeah okay
and the second question
oh you would like to add something uh
okay the second question is
at the end of the day however
do we really need to learn theta 0 or to
learn something like an oracle
an approximation of the distribution i
mean
yeah yeah yeah for many dust you
actually do as i mentioned all of these
examples but for many of those you
actually need an accurate uh
yeah uh but uh you know like there could
be some sub tasks and we'll see maybe at
the end of the second hour
how if you care for example about
revenue
you could bypass
learning the whole distribution of
violence you know if that's what you
care about
but then you know like you can view it
from the semi-parametric inference
viewpoint that what you care about is
revenue that's theta note
and that's your you're trying to
estimate you need the distribution of
volume which is another non-parametric
function that's you need that in order
to estimate that but you don't care
about it
so what the properties of these
estimators do we typically analyze some
finite sample properties like you know
bias you know is our estimate unbiased
as a sample
um variance of the estimator and the
mean squared there
and then you know large sample
properties are typically very important
as n goes to infinity does our estimator
converts to the truth
and very importantly in in so in social
science applications um
can we characterize the distribution
this asymptotic distribution of our
estimate so that we can
report confidence intervals on our on
the estimate of interest right so if
we're going to make a big decision
based on the estimate we want to know
how confident we are about the testament
and to do that we need to understand
what is the
the confidence interval say we want an
interval so that with 95 percent
probability the truth is going to lie in
that interval uh asymptotic normality
which is a sort of characterization of
the asymptotic distribution of our
estimate is going to help us
do that because if we know that roughly
uh based on you know some say root n is
alpha n
uh of our estimate when you normalize
that by root n it's asymptotically
normal you can put some normal distrib
you know some normal uh
distribution around your estimate
uh with some variance v and divide by uh
you know n and that would be um your uh
your proxy for a confidence interval
um and then the other uh thing that
people in econometrics many times study
is is these limit volumes that we
characterized the best limit of irons
that we could hope for across all
estimators that we can think of
and so that is the efficiency
okay
one general class of estimators that is
typically used in econometric problems
is what is known as the generalized
method of moments
many times all of our econometric
assumptions on the world like the fact
that people best respond or
the fact that this is an optimal price
or
other assumptions about how people
behave can be translated into moment
conditions that your data generating
distribution needs to satisfy
so typically you can translate them into
such a
a condition about the d of theta that i
mentioned before that in expectation
over d of theta
uh this moment which depends on the data
and theta
is equal to zero
so those assumptions about the world
typically give you such
constraints in the population limit
and given such
population limit constraints
a a natural analog of an estimator is
the empirical analog of that population
constrained
so you can write down the empirical
version of that expectation and solve
that empirical estimating equation
being equal to zero and that will give
you an estimated theta hat which you can
then analyze whether it's close to
the truth or not
for instance you know like if you're
saying a linear regression setup
where you assume that your data are
coming from some linear function of the
unknown parameter theta
plus an error term epsilon
that is mean zero conditional on the
covariates z
you can typically this will imply that
the following moment condition is
satisfied from your distribution that if
you multiply
the residual y minus zeta theta
by the covariates this is going to be
zero by a simple tower law because this
is just epsilon and excellent condition
when z is zero
so this is a moment condition that is
implied by our by your assumptions about
the world
that your error is mean zero
and then you can analyze the empirical
analog which is basically the ols
estimate
so this equivalently you can view this
moment as the derivative of the square
loss but you can also think of it as a
moment
constraint
another internal class of estimators is
where
your you express your parameter of
interest as the minimizer of some loss
function in the regression example it's
the square loss
so your parameter theta naught you might
be able to characterize that it is the
minimum of some criterion q naught
which depends on the distribution so
that's a
hypothetical criterion
but then you have empirical analogues of
that q naught maybe this q naught is a
popular expected loss and you can
replace that with an empirical loss and
optimize the empirical loss and that's
your estimate
one very uh you know typical example is
the maximum likelihood estimate where
your criterion is the likelihood and you
replace it with the empirical analysis
um
another example is where you start from
a moment condition but your moment
condition might uh
be over identified so you have you might
have more constraints than parameters
that you're estimating
so then you move to uh an estimator
where you minimize the some norm of
those moment constraints
and typically you would re-weight those
moments
to minimize variance of your estimate
and that's what this w matrix over here
is doing it's a matrix that is typically
chosen so that the variance of your
estimate is minimized so that you choose
moments that have lower variance than
others and that leads to the gmm
estimator which is basically the mean
falls into this extreme type of
estimators
why do we talk about these particular
types of estimators because there are
general theorems for them uh if for for
instance you know like you under very
benign assumptions
that for instance theta naught is a
unique maximum
that q the criterion is continuous and
uniformly converges over the space theta
to the population criteria and then you
can immediately get consistency so those
types of estimators will typically be
consistent
and this will for instance be satisfied
if that criterion
is
an expectation of some loss function
another type of uh general theorem that
you can get for these types of
estimators is asymptotic normality and
this is another reason why uh people in
econometrics tend to like formulating
their estimator as one of these
estimators because that would
immediately give you a sympathetic
normality and some you know easy to use
plug-in formulas for the
variance and the confidence interval
and
i'm gonna briefly show you a proof of
asymptotic normality uh it's a three
lines uh because we're also going to try
to prove sort of like use a variant of
that to analyze the two stage estimators
that we're going to see in games in the
next section
so how do you prove a symptomatic
normality for such an estimator
any question so far because before i
move into the three line proof
so uh so suppose you have an extreme
type of estimator equivalently you can
formulate it as a moment estimator where
the first order condition is satisfied
so you can since you're maximizing that
criterion the derivative the gradient of
your loss function is going to be equal
to zero
on average
this empirical average
so you could you could also have started
with
moment based estimators the proof would
be the same
and what do you typically do you uh take
that empirical analog
and you linearize that equation around
uh your
around the truth this hypothetical truth
that you're after
yes so you linearize it you apply a mean
value theorem that you apply here first
order taylor expansion and theta bar
will be some point in between
some point in between theta hat and
theta implied by the mean value theorem
now you can rearrange this and you're
going to have
root n of this difference that you care
about to characterize
so this is the
the distribution of this quantity is
what you try to characterize
can be written as the inverse of this
mean value jacobian
multiplied by this
root and normalized
empirical average
this quantity over here because theta
hat by consistency converges to theta
naught and theta bar is a point in
between
theta bar is also going to converge to
theta naught
and this empirical average is also going
to converge to the population average so
under some regularity conditions you can
show that this quantity over here is
going to converge in distribution
to this
expect
question what is the the rate that the
okay
so
this one converges to the same
distribution
okay so be clear for that though i mean
what happened to the
not because power
converges are not by consistency
uh and this empirical average converges
to the population by uh just as you know
you know you need some aggregate
conditions for that over the space but
so this quantity converges to this
hypothetical jacobian
expected certification evaluated at the
node
there's the delivery
yes yes so they think inside converts it
up and then
uh
you invoke another asymptotic theorem
called the continuity of the universe as
long as this station is bounded away
from zero it's eigenvalues this inverse
is going to converge to the inverse of
love
that's another asymptotic here
then this quantity over here is an
empirical average a rooted normalized
empirical average of some
random variable
for a random vector right
and by a central limit theorem this is
going to converge to this normal
distribution
and so then you apply what's known as
slots his theorem and says that this
converges in distribution to this this
converges to this uh
uh in probability that this is
convergent distribution to this this
whole thing is going to converge
distribution to a normal where you also
need to
three and pulse multiply these variance
by the
the inverse of the chakra
just to be sure
we say that theta hat minus theta 0
converges to 0 or root 10 times theta
[Music]
actually even get like something
stronger which is the distribution of
that uh difference
and then in practice so that's the the
typical proof there there are several
regular conditions there are alternative
proofs that use more complex
theorems
which avoid some of those regularity
conditions but this is what you will
find if you look at the standard
textbooks from the early 90s
in practice also uh people tend to use
bootstrap to estimate the variance of
that asymptotic distribution and then
plug it into a normal uh that
bootstrap-based estimate which is
slightly more accurate in finite samples
but you could also just do a plug-in
after you estimate theta
node you can plug in in the formula here
theta hat and that will also be an
accurate estimate a consistent estimate
of your
there values consistency theorems for
the boots that will converge uh there
are also some rates
but yeah so
yeah
rates on the difference
on the distance but
older proofs are more asymptotic newer
proofs
um
more
finite sample you can you can also pass
all the fine example rate
out of them but yeah
you need uh the other nice thing is that
typically if you formulate it like that
uh there is a meter like that then it
satisfies the regularity conditions
for the bootstrap to work
uh if you're because your estimate here
is sort of like satisfying what is known
as asymptotic linearity in the limit you
can view it as a
as a simple average of something
and whenever you satisfy somebody the
bootstrap also works for the reason that
the good stuff works for some labyrinths
and so that's one high level notation
but there are more recent proofs that go
beyond us
this
this is here yeah but this you can show
that if you take out and subtract
quantities those are going to be lower
than terms
and then you're going to be ending
ending up with this hypothetical thing
multiplying this average and that's
going to be the leaping term
uh and the others are gonna be lower or
they're
converging faster than one over then
okay
so and if you wanna look some for
example like in this year's earthquake
with morgan austin and paper on the
bootstrap when applied to more complex
machine learning estimators and provable
guarantees for the bootstrap so we have
a concrete process over there if you
want to look at more recent techniques
for proving bootstrap consistency
so
okay so i think i'm gonna not gonna
cover all of the things that i wanted to
cover but i might uh you know rush
through the dynamic games where i just
wanted to give you the rough idea but
i'm gonna definitely talk about
how do you apply these techniques to the
idealized scenario
we talked about in the beginning the
market and pregames
so
the high level idea that i was saying at
equilibrium agents have beliefs about
other players actions and best respond
if the econometrician observes the same
information about the opponents as the
player does
then we can estimate those beliefs from
the data in the first stage
uh it's going to be concrete in the next
next few slides and then you can you can
use best response inequalities to these
estimated beliefs in the second stage to
infer the parameters of the utility of
interest
so that's the high level structure of
how these estimators work
you first estimate those beliefs that
people have when they best respond from
the data non-parametrically
and then you use the best respond
inequalities to uh divide an
final step estimation strategy of the
parameter of interest
so going let's go back to the entry
games
we're going to be assuming
that the firms best respond
only an expectation in this case of
incomplete information where i don't
observe your private sock
so when i'm deciding whether to enter or
not
i'm going to be taking an
an expectation over your
decision to enter or not with respect to
epsilon 2.
so my expected pay of pi 1
is gonna not contain here your actual
choice in the end but it's going to be
your probability of entry
given the state of the market
so this is what i
am calculating as my expected profit
from entering
in expectation over epsilon 2 and this
is what you're calculating as your
expected profit profit from entry
in expectation over epsilon 1.
[Music]
it's a function of the distribution
right
so your probability of entry is a
function of the
distribution of the private shock and
the equilibrium strategy although some
distribution is known yes i know your
distribution of epsilon 2's i don't know
your instance realization of your
epsilon 2 but it's like an option i know
the distribution of your values
and i know my value
so
how much can you relax this assumption
like having a parameter you know
that then you estimate from the data say
i know your distribution
up to some parameter
and then i try to recover that from the
data assuming that the agent knows that
parameter
are you imposing the distribution here
of the absence or so okay so for the
particular
strategy i'm going to push here i will
there have been relaxations for
lifting that
but for this particular one i will yeah
sort of a high-level question which
connects to this is
how these assumptions about the
distribution of the epsilons connect to
the properties of the estimator we just
saw
yes i haven't looked lately at the
the the cases of non-parametric uh
assumptions of the error like what types
of rates but uh there but there is a
survey you can read as the actual during
the sort like in a semi-parametric world
where the distribution of our absolutes
which is a function is estimated
non-parametrically somehow from the data
and then you're plugging it in to
estimate the parameter of interest so
you need to understand how the errors
from the non-parametric component affect
okay so that is uh i don't know
here because we're going to be imposing
some parametric assumptions on those
distributions we're going to be getting
you know parametric rates
again not easily we're going to have
there's going to be some
something to work out here but yeah
so that's uh
so can you explain your technology here
so
pi one contains there are no variables
yes it's the conditional acceleration so
i wanted a conditional expectation
position on the epsilon one with an
expectation of epsilon two conditional
epsilon and and x
is it conditional
are you using the equilibrium yes so
they are using the equilibrium size
right it's a fixed point so they've
calculated some equilibrium styles in
sigma which is your probability of entry
conditional on x right and so when i
calculate my expected payoff from entry
i'm gonna be taking the what is the
probability of your probability of entry
uh conditional on
i know the distribution so i as a
player know exactly the distribution i
calculate the base mass equilibrium that
basis equilibrium has this form of
probability of
entry conditional on x
and that
equilibrium has to satisfy best response
conditions that when i decide to enter
this is my expected payoff
um
and it should be
that
my probability of entering
should be the probability that this
payoff is positive otherwise i wouldn't
end it
and your probability that this should be
probably the display of response
responding
uh
why am i doing probability matching
so you your goal is to make better one
and delta one for instance right or
better than delta two
so
uh
i'm just writing down here what does it
mean for these sigmas to be in
equilibrium and these are gonna help me
to estimate those better right they
don't do this they did this calculation
that you know internally to find a
fixed point and then decide whether to
enter or not
uh
but these equipment have to satisfy
these promises that
you know if you decide to enter when
this happens and you know if this is how
you decide whether it's vendor or not
this is your probability of entry so
because uh you know like we're at a
steady state this is what's going to the
other player's consideration
so this is the
equilibrium assumption now we haven't
said anything about the parametrics this
is just what is implied by our
assumption that people play a business
equilibrium in this game
and here comes you know that you can an
easy way to estimate these things is to
impose some uh parametric type of
distribution on these socks
the most
friendly one is this extreme value type
distributions
in machine learning you're going to call
them like a gambit distribution or like
uh you know the thing that gives rise to
the multiplicative weight updates uh
sort of algorithm but yeah so you're
going to make some assumptions about
those distributions that you're going to
say that uh that probably that are going
to give closed form
closed form solutions to this
probability calculation
so if your epsilon follows that extreme
value type distribution
this probability that this quantity is
positive
is equal is proportional to the to the
e to the
the first part the non-random part
so for this particular type of
distribution this probability is
proportional to that so it is logistic
function where the uh
you know this is the the utility part
the you know like the logit partner in
the logistic function
so that's what this gives us it gives us
this clause from solution
okay so this is just uh you know it's
not
trivial how you calculate fix points for
this
but
there must be some work i haven't gone
into having reviewed that for this
tutorial so i won't say much
the claim is that
they chose one fixed point
and
given the data i can estimate that fixed
point without any assumption because
given the data i observe x and i observe
y i
so i have x and y i i can calculate
nonparametrically what is the
probability of entry conditional on x
right so
this probability of entry sigma i of x
is there in my data
my data tells me what is that
probability that for each player right
so i do not i don't need to use even not
even the equilibrium assumption to
calculate that i can just estimate that
from the date
uh if you're player one um
and you don't know epsilon two how can
you assume that sn2 is also distributed
onto an extreme value
you know the distribution you don't know
the realization of that
sample
so you know that both socks are drawn
from this extreme value distribution but
you never see what the epsilon you got
i don't see what epsilon you got i just
know that your epsilon is distributed
based on that and my epsilon and you
know that my exponents is
knows the distribution and the value for
his own and only distribution for the
other players yeah so it's the same as
in a in being in a private auction right
i know the distribution of players and
safers are for simplicity that all
players distribute according to this
extreme type player values and we play
base numbers
so i can calculate those probabilities
if say the x's say are discrete so let's
say we only have like 10 types of
markets
i can go to every type of market x for
everybody the
realization of the
variable x
and i calculate the fraction of times
across all of my instantiations of that
type of market that player one entered
and the fraction of times that they
didn't end there and that's uh sorry the
fraction times that they enter and
that's the probability so i can have a
non-parametric estimate i calculate
these empirical averages for every
market type
if x is continuous then this is a
complicated continuous function to
estimate not parametrically but if x is
discrete then this is just
calculating empirical frequencies
and then once you have those estimates
you can plug them into these sort of
like fixed point equations like these
best response equations now
because now you have the estimate sigma
hat so it doesn't all of a sudden it
doesn't become a fixed point equation
it's like i gave you sigma 2 now give me
beta and delta given that sigma 1 must
be satisfying this
so if you give me sigma hat of my
opponent
my decision to enter is follows this
logistic rule and now estimating beta
and delta is a simple logistic
regression
where
x and sigma
minus i hat of x are the covariates
of that logistic regression
so i can run a logistic regression and
estimate beta i and delta
i i said before if the if the states if
the x's are discrete then estimating
non-parametrically sigma is just
empirical frequencies and there are you
can prove root n rates for those
empirical frequencies
and so you do have guarantees that your
first stage estimate is going to
converge to normal
and then
you have the second stage estimate which
depends on this first stage estimate but
the question is uh is the second stage
estimate which is now say
a gmm because or like a you know like a
extreme value or falls into these uh
types of estimators that we said in the
first stage in the first part of the
talk
does it still maintain those properties
that we said the only difference is that
we plugged in an inaccurate estimate of
something
in that moment
and so the question is does that
inaccurate estimate affect the
distributional properties and the error
rates of that final estimate and how
yeah yeah
they're very sensitive and that's why
some people have looked at
non-parametric
variants of these entry games where you
make nonparametric assumptions but yes
they're very sensitive but they give you
immense statistical power so you only
have like say 50 markets i'm not sure i
would go with the
not you know like the insensitive but
very statistically high variance
estimates for this particular effort
right so
you know
that's the trade of you facing practice
and so this question is a general
question about two stage estimators
so where
you
[Music]
you have a moment that does not only
depend on the parameter of interest but
also depends on other quantities that
you don't know
but you need to plug in and you've
estimated them in a first stage
and
doing the same type of slotsky
asymptotic normality
theorem
you are no longer you can no longer
easily argue that this is asymptotically
normal because it depends on this h hat
right which is a function of your data
but then you can do further
linearizations around that h hat
this is going to be a normal quantity
when you do a taylor expansion and then
the question is does this go to
uh to zero
and if you sort of rewrite it as one
over n times the first part and root n
times the second part
this will go to zero only if this root
and normalized first stage estimate goes
to
or won't actually go to zero if this
first adjustment goes to some normal
then you
with some work you can show that this
whole thing is still asymptotically
normal
so as long as you your first stage
estimate is asymptotically normal or
more concretely asymptotically linear
this whole two-stage approach will still
be asymptotically linear and so normal
and you can do your standard confidence
interval construction or base complex
intervals
but this is problematic when this h hat
is a
function even in a 1d space
this hud will not be root and consistent
because you're estimating
nonparametrically a function in a 1d
space so it won't have root and rates
will have slower than return rates
and so this type of approach is going to
be problematic in that situation so even
if you have just a single x
characteristic of your market and that
was continuous
and this approach trivially wouldn't
give you the
root and rates
um
but because i think we you know fma five
minutes
um there
there are approaches that will allow you
to still sell root and rates for these
two-stage estimators even if
that quantity that you don't know is
known is a non-parametric function
[Music]
and this is some you know like some
other work by
barry hong
kreiner and nicki pelos
and
remarkably shows that even if those
first stage believes you can't estimate
at return rates you can still estimate
the final parameter the target parameter
at written rates
uh
under what conditions
so
it requires that
those sigma hat estimates they're not
very slow like again you're going to
have this if they're n to the one
quarter consistent not true then
consistent
then you're going to get the return
consistency for the target so you get
like a squared improvement for the
target parameter of interest
um as long as you can estimate uh those
quantities at end to the one quarter
rates
which will be okay for a 1d variable x
uh
or it might be okay for
if you if you use adaptive estimators
for like machine learning based
estimators the and subject to some you
know like sparsity assumptions or
high dimensional linearity assumptions
other assumptions on your on your
beliefs which will be high level and
hard to check that your beliefs will
satisfy those assumptions you can also
solve that
but at least for yeah even for even for
the 1d case
i haven't uh i don't i don't recall
seeing like the proof that
sigma
like the properties that sigma will
satisfy which is the outcome of this
fixed point are all fixed points
satisfying certain smoothness
assumptions most probably yes but i
don't recall saying you need to
argue that your equilibria will satisfy
those high-level assumptions that you
typically impose for statistical
inference
sometimes these are hand-waved and
sometimes people do the do the job and
actually prove but many times these are
just hand weights
but there you go
all your
and the idea how to do that is you don't
use the actual logistic regression we
try to de-bias the logistic regression
estimate to remove uh
the effect
from the first stage estimate and this
leads to the literature or negan
orthogonality and
and i'm only going to be able to give
you pointers for that
uh if i have time i could go through the
proof but basically you add a bias
correction turret in your second stage
which will allow you to uh
to kill a first order term for that fine
from that final linearization so instead
of doing here a first order taylor
expansion around your h around your
eighth note you can do a second order
taylor expansion any minor programmable
is going to imply that the first order
term over here is going to be equal to
zero so if you choose your moment
correctly in the second stage you can
cancel the first term and then you're
gonna only be left with a second term
which then would only require that n to
the one quarter of your error uh goes to
zero so that's roughly the
proof approach
and
i think i'm going to stop here
was it
the final section that uh
um
i'm just gonna define what has been
people have worked on uh but i'm not
gonna give you the very details of the
estimation um
another very class a large class of uh
games that people have analyzed from the
economic perspective is dynamic
markovian games
where you assume that players play over
time and there's a you know a state of
the world st typically observed and
observed state of the world
people again have these private socks
these epsilon eyes that
happen at every period
and they're private to its player again
and only distributional assumptions are
being made about what i know about my
opponents
uh given uh the state of the world and
those socks
i'm gonna choose my action at the
current period
um
and uh
my action is gonna my profits are gonna
take this
additive form of some
deterministic profits that do not depend
on the private soc and some uh and some
private shock
profits so these are sort of like uh
yeah is the deterministic part and this
is the epsilon stock to your payoff at
that current period
and typically what you want to estimate
are these sort of like
uh
non-idiosyncratic payoff functions you
want to understand these functions
without the you know edition crafting
shock that doesn't serve like a random
noise
um
after players choose an action the state
transitions
as a function of both the action profile
of players
and the past period action
and
people assume that
what you observe is the outcome of a
steady state policy
so it's a mark of steady state mark of
equilibrium where people choose
a mapping from uh
from states and private socks
to an uh an action for that current
period
and
and that action is going to be
maximizing
my uh
my utility my expected discounted future
reward right so i'm gonna be calculating
a discounted future reward under this
markovian equilibrium assumption and it
has to be that what i chose now is
larger than the the expected pair of
discounted paper that i would have
chosen had i played any other action so
these are the computations that are
going into every player's head in order
to choose how to play
and under this assumption that people
play according to this markovian steady
state equilibrium you want to
reverse engineer and fund the find the
parameters of these
profits
which again you can use then to do all
of the things that we talked about why
uh econometric analysis is useful
this is still beijing this is like yeah
like a dynamic bayesian game um
where people typically apply this to
dynamic oligopoly markets so you have
two firms competing over time in some
market and this is how
you apply
these types of models to that and try to
estimate profit
and again the
estimation methods heavily depend on on
this distribution of our episodes that
we assume so there's still going to be
one step that's very brittle here which
is called the inversion step where you
go from probability choices of actions
into the deterministic parts of the
payoff so these new eyes
over here
you make assumptions that say that if i
observe the probability choice of a of a
player like as a function of the state
of the world
uh and
then i can reverse engineer
and
find the map the new i or something so
like if you assume that these epsilons
are extreme type then you can
use a sort of like a logic rule again
and again those are these estimation
properties will be brittle to those
assumptions
um
so that was
that's it so for the first part so the
the recap of the main idea at
equilibrium if agents have beliefs about
other players actions and best response
and the econometration observes the same
information as what you observe about
your opponent you can take these two
stage estimation approaches where you
estimate non-parametrically some
components of the observed distribution
and then use best response inequalities
either simple ones in the study game or
if you go into the slides more
complicated ones in the markovian game
you can
recover the structural parameters that
you care about
and these are some references that if
you want to
look into more detail
thanks
there were several questions during the
discussion the talk
is there any burning questions
[Music]
kind of non-asymptotic analysis
it seems to depend on a lot of
assumptions like we're in a linear model
and
we have error estimated correctly and
the stat how do how do people think
about
these convergence bounds
they think
like oh this model isn't exactly
accurate but maybe it's close enough
do they think these bounds don't mean
very much do they think
these bounds are what we can prove now
but in 10 years we're going to have
fancier models improve
bounds more general cases and those are
going to be useful like how do they
so many times the approaches that i made
there are two uh
two ways to do it either you truly
believe about your model or you just
look at what your estimator is solving
for and you try to abstract the way and
say oh i don't it's not really that my
sweater uses all the information about
the model i
i i
imposed but it just uses this moment
condition and this is what i'm
estimating and then try to give other
interpretations of what they're
estimating
uh that's more general than assuming a
linear model um so that's one approach
uh in general though um
the reason why
people try to prove these bonds is not
to say that we're
it's mostly in order to put uncertainty
intervals
even subject to the model that you're uh
that you're imposing right so that is
why they most of these are important
because even if i'm assuming that the
model is correct
what i'm getting out of this is
a i mean and you know how certain you
are given the data that you have even
under my assumptions right so that's why
these are useful
uh
yeah and so even if it's converging to
some constrained solution
given the model that you assumed uh
you you want to know the uncertainty of
your of your estimate
um
so they're kind of like optimistic
balance in some ways yeah the
best case
that we have yeah
yeah
like a little some particular place
where structural committees are being
used is uh understanding uh like you
know like you wanna emerge if the merger
is uh
and you do some competition and
structure
they're not used i mean in economics
professions they're used but in actual
decision-making in authorities they're
not used they're too complex
[Music]
empirical papers where people apply i
don't know what they use in the in the
fed or something or whatever
these things are being used but i've
also seen you know like demand
estimation problems like demand
estimation uh approaches i've actually
seen used in in practice even within
microsoft so where it's not it's a
single it's sort of like a single agent
problem
uh
yeah
all right so interesting discussions for
the coffee